Всім привіт! Мене звати Анна Домніч
І саме зараз час трохи розім'ятись після навчання
Я думаю, кожен із вас знає,
що спорт – це сила, краса та здоров'я
І це дуже корисно для нашого організму
Тож, пропоную вам доєднатись
до наших драйвових руханок
і зарядитись позитивом.
Розпочинаємо!
Всім привіт! Ви готові до нашого уроку спорту?
Я вже дуже засумувала за нашими руханками
У нас сьогодні в гостях неймовірно талановиті
Женя Кот
Наталія Татарінцева
Ви готові, друзі, до нашого уроку спорту?
Так
Супер!
[лунає музика]
[лунає дзвінок]
Друзі, мені здається, чи продзвенів дзвінок?
Так швиденько закінчився наш крутий урок
Я вам дуже вдячна!
Ви неймовірні. Дякую вам!
[плескання в долоні]
Давайте скоріше, бо мені на математику
До зустрічі!